You want to let them crash
us into some capital city?
— Is that it?
— Oh, come on.
Is that what you think
is going to happen?
I have no idea.
No.
Obviously.
Yeah, but I'm not going
to wait and find out, am I?
So what are you going to do?
You're going to
just attack them?
No one's asking
you to join in.
You'll get yourself killed.
Listen, if you've not got the balls, all you have to do is say.
Wallets, tablets, devices—
Water?
Put your table down.
Sorry?
Still want sparkling?
I'm OK.
Which did you see?
Water?
If it was A, do nothing.
If it was B, and
you're sure it's B—
Believe me, I won't.
—turn on your reading light.
You good?
Here, have some.
Take one.
Thank you. Pass it down.
Water?
Water, anyone?
What's up?
Shh.
Sky watch, this is Mars.
We have visual with a
figure mid fuselage.
Step back.
Contact is female.
Agent 130.
Contact is being attacked.
Hostage, do not communicate.
Come with me.
We need someone to land the plane.
We're flying around. We.
You speak Hungarian? Yes. Yeah.
We need to persuade the Hungarians
to let us land this
Hungarian air traffic control.
Speak English.
I know. Don't eat Hungarian.
We do because the hijackers don't.
So if you can get a message down
to them in Hungarian,
this could all be over.
Pass the scissors.
Which one was it?
It was me.
Right.
Come here.
Please!
Don't look at me.